desde posturas comunes hasta pedidos
puntuales varios líderes de
latinoamérica y el caribe se
pronunciaron en miércoles en la cumbre
mundial de naciones unidas donde
venezuela pidió una vez más el fin de
las sanciones criminales de las
potencias occidentales y el apoyo de la
onu en los diálogos con la oposición
ratificamos nuestro pedido nuestra
exigencia a que se levanten todas las
sanciones
criminales contra la economía venezolana
contra la sociedad venezolana por parte
de los eeuu norteamérica y por parte de
los gobiernos de la unión europea
señalaron las crisis migratorias como
uno de los mayores desafíos para la
región y llamaron a la inversión
extranjera la única solución para
detener el flujo migratorio irregular
debe basarse en la construcción de muros
de prosperidad que le permitan al ser
humano mejorar sus condiciones de vida
en su propio país los líderes hablaron
de pandemia resaltando la inequidad al
momento de repartir vacunas
transformación del sistema internacional
de salud en especial de la organización
mundial de la salud debido a la
inequidad
reflejada de la distribución de vacuna
contra el cobismo a los países en vías
de desarrollo aunque es sus estilos para
gestionar la salud pública difieren
entre sí brasil por ejemplo recibió
varias críticas tras los escándalos del
contagio del ministro de salud y la
aparición del presidente bolsonaro sin
tapabocas en medio de una multitud de
nueva york